the president will go in announced that he
will launch a full federal government effort
to try to protect
access to safe and legal abortions
in texas president bailén said in a
statement that he directed the
justice and health departments to
investigate what steps  can be taken to
combat the new law that took effect in
texas on wednesday the law prohibits
abortions in that state after six
weeks of pregnancy experts say
that most women do not know they
are pregnant before that point and
the new texas law  does not allow
exceptions in cases of rape or
incest the supreme court decided not to
intervene to prevent texas law from
taking effect even though it
goes against the 1973 roe v. wade decision
in which the supreme court said
that the  The US Constitution
protects the right to abortion without
excessive government restrictions,
but Nancy Pelosi announced that the House
of Representatives will vote.  on a new
law to legalize abortion at the
national level a new law of congress would
supersede any decision of the
supreme court but it is unlikely that the
senate will approve such a law reporting in
washington to the ex central limón